how you know in YouTube welcome to the
Rubin report I am Dave Rubin and I have
with me Nicki de Lucia and Cara Santa
Maria and we got a lot of crazy stories
for you so let's get right to it there
is either an Ebola outbreak that will
end human society or not that big of a
deal happening right now it depends who
you're listening to so we want it to
break down some facts for you so right
now in western Africa they are having
the worst Ebola outbreak
that they've ever had there have been
about 930 deaths and about 1,700 cases
and this is going on in Sierra Leone
Liberia and Nigeria and we've got some
more info for you the disease spreads
via bodily fluids so it is not airborne
we gotta just put that out there right
now because that's what a lot of people
are afraid of the death count has grown
to 887 as of August 4th so I was just
giving you the updated numbers with a
total of about 1600 likely diagnosed
victims so far the fatality rate from
this outbreak has been about 60% which
could rise to about 90% and right now
there is no vaccine for Ebola though the
World Health Organization reports that
there are several being tested and let's
look at a timeline of what's going on
here the first Ebola epidemic was in
1976 and disease killed 280 people which
was 88% of the people who became
infected okay so now let's bring this
back to America for a second so we had
two doctors over there that were
treating people with Ebola and they got
affected infected with Ebola they are
now in Atlanta at the CDC and they are
quarantined so we'll see what happens
with that people have been freaking out
Donald Trump where who I get all my
information from he was on Twitter
freaking out about why are we bringing
these people back again it is not
airborne but I don't have any great
faith in the government that they're not
gonna somehow screw this up and make it
airborne who knows we will see but
before we get into all the specifics
let's just look at a little info on what
Ebola actually does okay so symptoms
typically begin four to nine days after
exposure though the incubation period
could
for up to 21 days the first couple days
days one through three you have flu-like
symptoms and profound weakness days four
through seven patients may also have
vomiting diarrhea nausea low blood
pressure headaches and anemia day seven
through ten toward the end of the
illness there's confusion and bleeding
both internal and visible all of this
progresses toward coma shock and death
okay so pretty bad stuff kara clean up
all the science messes that I create so
I'm not even going to give you a
question I'm just gonna talk little bit
of cleanup mode yes so first and
foremost the earliest outbreak ever of
Ebola was in central Africa obviously
physicians have never seen Ebola so they
weren't sure how to contain it that's
why the death toll was as high as it was
and that's why the actual rate of people
dying versus people getting infected was
nearly 90% now that is the the number
that a lot of people are citing now
Ebola you know has a 90% death rate but
what we're seeing in West Africa now is
actually closer to 60% what we would see
in America if Ebola took hold here would
be significantly lower because we have
significantly better health practices
than we're seeing in those regions so
that's number one
to remember a lot of people are really
really afraid of these two physicians
coming over - they're actually an Emory
in an Emory hospital all right so I
think the the thing was built by the CDC
is like right next door so they've got a
lot of CDC influence there there is very
very very minimal risk of anybody else
getting infected these individuals are
heavily quarantined there are so many
safeguards being taken Ebola is very
easily killed by disinfectants cleaning
up after an individual is a very easy
way to prevent transmission of the
disease it's actually quite hard to
catch one way that a lot of physicians
will tell you to think about Ebola is
think about it like HIV so you can catch
HIV from transmission of bodily fluids
from blood from semen from saliva if
there's blood in the saliva it's very
hard to catch HIV by shaking somebody's
hand by sitting
the same you know train is them Ebola is
very similar in that way so I think
that's a really important thing for
people to realize that they don't often
yes away people talking about that that
was pretty much so I wanted you to clean
it up and that was what I was gonna say
to you is I wanted to do this segment
because this isn't what people are
talking about if you turn on the news
you know pandemic freaked out everything
yeah and of course that's what the news
is trained us to do so what is this just
the nature of the news it's 20 we got
three people out at all cost yeah I
think it's so they can keep watching
yeah why like if they thought oh well
all is well they're gonna turn their
televisions off and then just go about
their day yeah so you know they want to
sit in front of it they want to see like
the craziness ensue
and and and they want to keep people
watching so they just they don't tell us
that yeah thank you yeah what are you I
think one thing also that's important to
remember is that I mean 1,600 people is
an outbreak and like this is dangerous
but Ebola is not what you read in hot
zone didn't work out that well for a day
it's really good and she yeah she died
in the end and here's the thing if you
were an aid worker in West Africa in
Sierra Leone in Nigeria not in Nigeria
Nigeria there's only one case and it's
not even a confirmed Ebola case oh maybe
it's two but that was that was the big
initial fear said it spread to Nigeria
which is actually a large populated
country in in the capital there but
Sierra Leone and Guinea and where else
is it in West Africa Liberia exactly
these are less populated areas the
reason that you see this huge jump
between 1976 and and now is that they
are more urbanized more people can get
on planes so there are people who have
access to moving around Africa that they
didn't have before and also distrust of
Western medicine has spiked in West
Africa and what we're seeing is that the
aid workers are going in and they're
saying you may be infected they're
taking family members away and the
family members are coming back in body
bags and this is very frightening to
these individuals also it's customary in
Africa that in death rituals they
actually wash
bodies and this is a really easy way to
transmit the disease and so a lot of
people are catching it and they're not
listening to the council that says you
cannot come in contact with the infected
it's the only way to stop this right so
you've given us a lot of the heavy
lifting here I of course watched the
first episode of the strain last night
which didn't help my paranoia at all
because that's pretty much all it's
about so all right now that we've gotten
sort of the factual part of it so let's
let's go with the fun jump part of it is
the contagion part in the outbreak part
do you think one day that that stuff is
eventually going to end up here like
those movies I love both of those movies
do you think that that's sort of not
with this specifically but it could just
somehow it could become something could
be it could be a form of terrorism in a
way if somebody wanted to do that they
could use it as a form of terrorism I
actually I wanted to ask like I had
heard that there is a serum that is
working because they're saying that
there's no vaccine but now they do have
a serum that seems to be working they
shipped it over to Africa what is it
what is that well here's the here's the
issue here there are a lot of treatments
that are in the works that we know might
work on organisms that aren't human you
know that way we can have an Ebola a
type of Ebola in a pig or in a monkey
and then we're going to or you know
we're gonna try and treat it and there
have been really big strides that have
been made in the lab unfortunately this
is a big sticking point for a lot of
people because if we do go into these
countries and we do try a treatment that
ends up either failing or that ends up
having some sort of horrible side effect
that distrust is going to spike even
more and so what we know now is the best
way to treat Ebola is to quarantine the
victims the victims may die they may not
depending on how strong their immune
systems are but if you quarantine them
you won't see any more spread of the
disease that's the number one thing to
do
as far as a pandemic an epidemic that
could take out human I mean it'd be so
good we've seen it with bubonic plague
we've seen it with Spanish flu we've
seen like horrible horrible diseases
that we didn't understand at that point
that we didn't know how to contain and I
don't think it's that unlikely a
scenario that's something like that
could happen of course medicine has
grown
leaps and bounds it's a really good book
by David Kwan man called spillover
that's all about this and I recommend it
to anybody who who reads still there's
probably an audiobook but I would say
that my bigger fear I agree it would be
weaponizing certain types of diseases in
order to make them difficult to treat
and in order to make them heavily
transmissible it would be yeah yeah yeah
it would be engineered so alright so
last thought on this Lu finish up is how
much can we pay attention to this stuff
man you know what I mean like you can
worry about the specifics of this yeah
and then you can worry about the terror
and all or all that how much brain power
are you giving this stuff on on a
day-to-day basis I think I just check in
daily check the news kind of like you
know click on things and and I think
that's all you can do you just kind of
like educate yourself and then don't
freak out about it I mean that's that's
what they want you to do they want you
to live in and still fear in you so that
you freak out and you keep watching the
news all day long and and it's know just
like educate yourself and move on and
let the fear go all right well yeah
don't listen to Donald Trump alright
well I hope we did a little bit of what
Nicki just said right there so that you
got some facts that maybe you won't be
freaking out but you know a little
something and you can do a little more
research and Kerri you get a gold star
so it seems to me that there is some
really really bad stuff going on in the
world that nobody is talking about so
Isis which is the Islamic state in Syria
they're also known as ISIL which is the
Islamic state and they Levant
and now they're just being called is is
la McStay t' they have been going on a
rampage basically through Iraq Iraq
really is no longer a country in any way
that we think countries operate Syria of
course is in the worst civil war going
on in the world right now and about 170
thousand people have been killed so
we're gonna show you an extremely
extremely graphic video so there is your
warning this is horrible what we're
about to show you but I'm bringing this
up because nobody's talking about this
and and I'm shocked and I really don't
understand why so again warning this is
has developed several the Qualicum you
know the dollar semi-hollow already we
probably Vanessa lemon my woman never
Allah I mean how would I know what's in
it
Polly oh well a TM Sara hold it up or
bow out hey to enthuse them Alma can
determine hadn't us about them key so
what you're seeing there the beheadings
are of Syrian soldiers loyal to Bashar
al-assad done by Isis now of course it's
hard to tell who the good guys are at
hard to tell who the bad guys are which
is part of the problem and I suspect
that's partly why the media isn't
talking about this because we like
really obvious things or seemingly
obvious things the uk-based Syrian
Observatory for Human Rights says at
least 85 government soldiers loyal to
Assad died there right now as we tape
this there is an ethnic group in Iraq
called the ZD they are tracked about
fifty thousand of them are trapped in
the mountains of Iraq surrounded on all
sides by Isis they are literally
starving to death
nobody's talking about it and nobody's
doing anything I don't know what we
should do but it seems like we should at
least be talking about it so let's talk
about that why is nobody talking about I
get what's going on in in Israel into
Gaza
terrible I get but why are we seemingly
unable to discuss two things because
we're so busy talking about the Ebola
virus we're not talking about this I
honestly don't know why people aren't
talking about this I mean at this point
in time they now run in one third of
Iraq that is a large percentage of the
country and they're now going into
Lebanon and Turkey and they're you know
this is yesterday they went into Lebanon
yesterday this is a crack this is a
crisis and nobody's
and I don't I honestly I don't know why
yeah is this kind of the perfect what
this seems to me is that this is the
perfect storm of george w bush [ __ ] up
everything by by creating a war in iraq
that we shouldn't have had yes and then
sort of yeah and then obama was sort of
the perfect president of disengagement
he that's what he said from beat one
nice job of that well even though i mean
perfect in if you wanted a perfect storm
of sort of terrible things to happen i
don't think it was his intent but when
he gave that big speech in cairo he sort
of said we're gonna pull back and let
you guys do stuff and that's and that's
fine but it's sort of the perfect storm
of two presidents doing completely
different things in a row to allow all
this to happen well i think i think i
mean even more than that there's an
issue trying to force a governmental
structure on a people who aren't
interested or willing to receive it
fundamentally that's a problem but but
beyond that i think going back to the
original question why is nobody paying
attention to this my cynical answer
would be that neither of these groups
are our allies yeah and because neither
of their these groups are allies we have
no political reason to to talk about
this human rights crisis and that's
detrimental to i think our understanding
i mean i am embarrassed to say that i'm
sitting here and i know very little
about the geopolitical conflicts that
are happening in these areas and that's
mostly because i haven't done my due
diligence but it's not yeah it's not
there you have to really dig for this
and when you talk about we know what's
going on in Israel with with the West
Bank with Gaza we know that because
Israel is a huge political ally of the
American government and you're not gonna
see any kind of political figures in
America speaking up for Gaza ins for
Palestinians you're not and and I mean
what you believe about that way you
don't believe about that it's a very
tricky situation it's pretty it's pretty
obvious where the allegiance of America
lies in that scenario in this scenario
what is it gonna be with Bashar is it
gonna be you know I mean like right like
we sort of think it should be with the
government in Iraq that we built but we
don't seem to be
doing much for that and also I think I
think when something becomes so
incredibly destabilized how much is kind
of putting all of your stock into a
government that's that's losing control
going to end up kind of cashing out in
the long run and that's really
unfortunately the way that the American
government looks at these situations
their strategic individual people are
head counts you know and no [ __ ]
horrible pun intended here but I think
more more than the political and more
than the the war that's happening there
what nobody's talking about is the fact
that like people are dying in a very
kind of savage savage draconian way so
is that is that then part of it that
this is so savage that partly you know
it everyone keep saying the images out
of guys are horrible which they are but
there's a definitive narrative it's a
bomb that drops on the award that we
recognize yes and it's that's how we've
seen war yeah you know this is this is
not that this is this is savage this is
like it's like some medieval yeah it is
[ __ ] evil it's something you'd see on
Game of Thrones you haven't seen on Game
of Thrones like this is something we
don't understand maybe maybe that's
another reason people aren't talking
about it's like how do you how do you
begin to talk about this where does this
mentality come from yeah you know how
does somebody I mean how does somebody
an al Qaeda has disavowed this group
because of their their behavior because
it's so savage so like how does someone
become the person that beheads another
human being and puts it on display for
everyone to see I just that's and why I
mean why I mean why aren't we doing
anything about it I mean it's a massacre
yeah you know Rwanda happened other
things have happened where there's been
massacres and yes we waited and waited
awaited or we did not do anything about
it and maybe that was political because
there was no political like there was no
incentive there's no privacy for us
there's no right now look there is a lot
of oil way obviously especially
especially in Iraq I don't know what
we're supposed to do but this thing
right now with the Yazidi in the in the
mountains they're literally dying of
starving children yeah
that's existed in Iraq for thousands of
years yes I guess we could have some
airstrikes on the ISIS soldiers that are
around the mountains you know to mean
I'm not calling for more military
intervention but like is there something
we could do that wouldn't risk any
American lives yeah or just I mean
simple humanitarian aid and I know that
there's gonna be pushback that it's
really hard to deliver humanitarian aid
when there's military intervention on
the other side right what you tried to
do we've seen this happen all the time
or we've seen this happen historically
in Africa where we tried to deliver
humanitarian aid warlords will pick up
the the meal packages whatever we're
delivering keep them from the people the
warlords are getting richer it's it's a
it's complicated as [ __ ] I think there's
something to be said about a group of
people that seems like they're behind
the rest of the world and I think that
that's a mentality that's hard for us to
sit with like we should be past this
right like we're more modern than this
and when you see you bother them exactly
the rest of the world is more modern
this group is so behind is so
ass-backward that it's like you were
saying there's such a disconnect how do
you even begin to intervene because the
arguments that you make the diplomacy
that you try to do doesn't translate and
that becomes a huge sticking point I
think that's where the real difficulty
lies so final thought I mean is there
anything that we should be doing do you
think I mean we're just letting it go to
hell in a handbag I I don't know I mean
I for me I feel like yeah there's
there's 50,000 people that are up on a
hill now running away from these people
and I feel like and any point in time I
know it's complicated
but I feel like where the United States
we can do anything we want to do and you
know these people are just gonna die if
somebody doesn't help them and we've
gone into their countries and we've you
know created havoc and we haven't
stabilized anything as as we can see and
then we just left okay well now we're
just gonna leave and we're gonna leave
you to deal with pick up the pieces yes
what are you problem that also goes to
what I meant about the over
the bush-obama respond up so terribly so
even right do we have a responsibility
even even if we don't want to yeah and
we believe in the idea of disengaging if
we're the ones that screwed it up do we
at least owe 50,000 people help the
people do something I don't know I don't
go into someone's house and make a mess
and then be like alright I'm gonna go
home now and leave your kitchen in
disarray
like I hope someone clean up their
kitchen and then I leave but then again
I you know I was raised with manners now
we ride it around alright from Ebola to
Isis to robots taking over we haven't
done a story on the robots in a couple
Elan musk you know him he created Tesla
and SpaceX he had some interesting
tweets and some comments about how he
fears robots more than he fears nuclear
war let's look at a couple tweets it's
worth reading super intelligence by beau
strim we need to be super careful with
AI artificial intelligence potentially
more dangerous than nukes hope were not
just the biological bootloader for
digital super intelligence unfortunately
that's increasingly possible now the
book he's talking about is called super
intelligence paths dangers and
strategies by Nick Bostrom now we've got
an excerpt from the book we cannot
blithely assume that a super
intelligence will necessarily share any
of the final values stereotypically
associated with wisdom and intellectual
development in humans scientific
curiosity benevolent concern for others
spiritual enlightenment and
contemplation renunciation of material
acquisitiveness a taste for refined
culture or for the simple pleasures in
life humility and selflessness and so
forth now if you've watched the other
clips that we've posted from this
episode we went from Ebola to Isis and
all this other bad stuff in the world I
don't know how much of that all that
good stuff about humanity that he's
talking about we have going on in the
world right
no I was just thinking enlightened where
enlightened yeah yeah look right Elan
musk obviously knows a lot about the
future a lot this is a guy who's on the
forefront of this of getting us off this
planet and at least while we're on this
planet maybe using some electric cars
before we destroy it all freakin thing
how much credence do you give his tweets
and this idea that the robots are gonna
get us before the nuclear war first of
all I never say never to anything never
or always it's just one of those I do
not put it past anyone to create some
kind of robot but why would you want to
do that I just don't understand why you
would want to create something that's
smarter than you right well isn't it
more that we're just gonna lose control
of them if you any of these scientific
sci-fi movies like it's all that we try
to do something good but then of course
they end up taking over yeah there's a
lot of common terminators there's a lot
of conversations and this articles about
like a benevolent robot a robot that yes
is is kind of tasked with protecting the
humans and okay let's think of a
worst-case scenario to protect a human
is to protect a human from harming
another human well maybe the best way to
protect them from harming each other to
lock them all into cages which is that
was I Robot you're gonna have to read
the book or you can see the Will Smith
movie but that was exactly what happened
the robots turned because they realized
that we were killing each other so then
they turned up my problem with these
kinds of arguments and yes I would argue
that Elon Musk is is a futurist I would
argue that he has he has some very good
ideas about how human society can and
could move towards the future
Elon Musk though is not a philosopher
Elon Musk is actually not a scientist
he's a very rich man who hires a lot of
very smart people to do things that he
thinks are good things to do and most of
the time those are very good things to
do but let's not you know put him on a
really big pedestal second to that I
think that there is a this entire
conversation is predicated on the idea
that artificial intelligence is capable
of what you're talking about
many scientists don't think that's the
case we have futurists like Ray Kurzweil
michio kaku who think there's gonna be a
singularity we're going to be downloaded
into the internet and we're not going to
need our physical bodies anymore no I
saw the matrix yeah a lot a lot a lot of
neuroscientists and a lot of
computational neuroscientist computer
engineers who work in that field are
very skeptical that we will ever get AI
to this place we know we have the
computing power we don't understand
enough about how the brain works to be
able to build a computer that computer
that could move it yeah actual human
brain activity right so that is an
interesting point and that brings me to
my next question is do you think we've
already started this so in other words
we have the technology and we're all
walking around with this stuff in our
hand right we've all got an iPhone and
we're all doing this stuff all day long
so the technology part is there and then
the other part the intelligence part is
just us it's our brains that we're
constantly putting into it all day long
with our twitter and instagram and all
that so we're becoming the machines
ourselves right
well yeah but with a brain kind of a
computer that way you know neurons fire
and it's did you know in a certain
direction and like we we're already
wired for that in a big way you know we
just yes we understand most of us right
or wrong and make we're emotionally
intelligent in that way you just go back
to like wow I mean just why like why I
mean like it's spiders and ants aren't
walking around being like oh I wish you
know humans were made so they can crush
us and they can step on us and destroy
us like one day I just don't I don't
understand that that's interesting so do
you think humans fundamentally have some
desire to destroy ourselves like we love
Godzilla movies and we love destruction
movies is there some weird psyche it's
like because we do sit on the top of the
you know the food pyramid so to speak
it's like there is some fascination with
creating something that is bigger than
us I mean we're already fascinated with
God and the idea of God and the idea of
the bigness you know that there is
something bigger than us like why not
create that weight power real quick does
God exist yes or no no okay
i-i-i think the issue here well first of
all i have to say the brain and the
computer do not work the same way
fundamentally they don't work the same
way and that's something we have to
understand it's hard to understand that
because the media tells us that they
work the same way cuz it's easy to use
analogies like just like in a computer
your brain does this but it's [ __ ]
there are a lot of people who try to
model computers after the human brain
and they've been very successful making
computers smarter and faster and better
what is the fundamental difference
between like the brain and like the
computer and how they're wired so when
we talk about and and this I you might
even want to cut this out we'll see I'm
gonna try and keep it short but I can
tell you just from personal experience
and granted this was you know almost ten
years ago maybe now when I was in
graduate school I was working in a
neuroscience lab where we took mouse
neurons we took the brain cells and we
put them on these little plates and we
could we could calculate all the
different ways that they fired and I was
working with a physicist who is now at
Los Alamos and he was doing
computational neurophysiology where he
would literally look at three neurons in
a row and he would look at types of
networks and say if this one fires and
this one fires how does this one react
if this one fires in this one fires how
does this work that's three neurons you
have billions of these things in your
brain it's the capabilities of the brain
are so far beyond the computational
power that we understand right now
computers are fast right they can hold a
lot of data but their reasoning
abilities that computers have are
nowhere near the reasoning abilities
that the human brain has been able to
have and funded by the way they can beat
us in jeopardy but they can't below
exactly and also and also I've got to
make this point we still don't know in
the neurosciences how consciousness
arises the concept of self how does it
go from individual neurons to being
awake and alert and aware and until we
understand that which is kind of the
holy grail of neuroscience I have
absolutely no fear that a computer is
going to become self-aware and take over
yeah that's great
final thought how long till we have
human-robot marriage start having sex
all right well that's terrible
Trump said 2030 so that's I'm going with
that there you go
all right let's get off the serious
stuff for a little bit and talk about
party schools the Princeton Review they
released their top ten party schools and
this is based on a survey of about a
hundred thirty thousand students at
three hundred seventy nine schools let's
look at the results Syracuse University
number one University of Iowa University
of California at Santa Barbara West
Virginia University University of
Illinois at urbana-champaign Lehigh
University Penn State University of
Wisconsin at Madison Bucknell and
University of Florida these are the big
party schools that's where everybody's
doing the drinking and what if what else
is kids doing now smoking smoking is
stuck in the marijuana we just had weed
in my know he just didn't know about all
the I was so stoned I did not even find
out about the other stuff so I love
things like this because first off
obviously it's it's somewhat selective
and anecdotal of course I don't know
that we can really rank them in any real
way but what do you think's going on
over at the Syracuse what's happening up
there it's it's northern New York it's
upstate right it's not really cold cold
body heat baby I went I went to
Binghamton University was about 45
minutes away it was not a huge party
school again that was why I was smoking
all the week there was was it because
they populate like how big was the
school itself Binghamton's about 12,000
at the time Syracuse is closer to like
40,000 after party 12,000 I get I would
just had this bond he was either
no no I was literally getting stoned I
was getting stoned and watching CNN
which is what led me Artie I used to see
things and wolf blitzer's beers
I don't know University of Georgia
actually I'm from Georgia and a huge UGA
fan and my brother was at UGA when they
were deemed like the number one party
school in the country and of course UGA
was very unhappy with that so they
started sending out vans and just
raiding bars all like all throughout the
downtown and just right like going in
and putting like anywhere between like
20 and 30 kids and vans and patty wagon
yeah have you got fish like yeah so same
people at Syracuse beware I mean maybe
that's the what happened they're coming
for ya yeah did already I think put out
a statement that was like we do not
strive to be a party school that is not
you know we are academics are first so
it's like this is almost the list you
don't want to be on because then
administration's gonna crack down and
you're like in bathroom experience yeah
so really you want to be on the list of
like 11 through 20 because then nobody
talks about you when you're getting a
lot of partying out yeah then you're
good how much of the college experience
though is just that like a good part of
college you know what I mean that you
need to get I just some of that yeah do
it like I mean being an adult you have
so much responsibility and then you get
married and then you have kids and then
it's really hard to drink you know
because somebody has to get up at 6:00
a.m. with the baby so I just get it I
told my brother before he went to
college I was like sleep with as many
women as you want to drink as many beers
as you want to like have a great time
because once you get out of college the
real world starts and sometimes it is
not fun yeah I very vividly remember
being in college and all my relatives
every adult that I knew would be like
this
the best yeah your life blah blah blah
yes he was we were like stress though
like I was like stress for example the
green or something like you're like that
you and just go for something like
really smart but I okay I have a bit I
did I Dave partied every ball you did I
don't drink now and I never have but I
did a lot of and so and and I think the
crazy sir but I like your advice because
honestly I think that college is the
time to just get laid a lot like wear
condom but get laid because I think that
it's it's also good experience to get
out there experience other people you
can be free it's kind of like socially
acceptable which is a bit weird like you
don't want to do that in the workplace
like you don't [ __ ] where you eat but
like you can totally [ __ ] where you go
to college like you can you know what I
mean like right get laid have fun I was
doing it I was having fun and but you
know it's like there's certain people
that getting high is more fun than going
to it it's gonna work well did you also
make another point a lot of these people
that are going to colleges some of them
come from really small towns where it's
like you know like for me I always said
to my brother or my sister like you know
my mom's a superintendent of a school
system my dad you know they're part of a
big family business they're like you
know but just be polite while you're
there like don't get you know wasted
embarrass yourself and have everyone in
town talk about it right and there is
that that existed and all these small
town communities so when you go to
college there's an anonymity that
happens it's like nobody back home knows
what I mean and it's awesome
and you get to start over you get to
make new friends you get to be a
whatever person you're trying to figure
out who you are at that time try a new
identity have fun with yeah so this way
this was a very pro party segment pretty
much think so I will bring it to one
serious thing at the end we always do
these stories about how expensive
college is becoming so we know weird and
then people that are college educated
aren't getting good jobs even anymore so
is college sort of just making itself
irrelevant because because of all the
partying in a weird way now do I sound
like an old man like it's becoming real
expensive and they're just partying and
they can't get the job so I mean I think
that it's it's a bit polar to say it's
becoming irrelevant
I do have huge problems with how
expensive it is I think that there are
huge overhauls we should make and the
way that we fund
colleges you know I'm all for like the a
lot of European countries you give
service to your country and in exchange
you get an education I do think though
it depends on what you're studying I
think there are certain majors that are
incredibly necessary like there are
certain things you can't do unless you
go to college like you're not going to
be good at doctor or a lawyer yeah or I
mean really a lot of things but there
are things that you can be self-taught
at and but I do think that the college
experience is important for kind of
personal growth especially if you did
come from a small town especially if you
did come from a place where your parents
were overbearing where you didn't have
any individuality where you couldn't
kind of step out on your own and learn
how to fail that's I think for me one of
the most important parts about college
is learning how to fail pick yourself
back up keep going it's a great point
yeah all right there great point we'll
end it on a great point here so we do a
lot of stuff obviously on religious
extremism around here and there is no
shortage of it but I found this story
that I thought was kind of interesting
showing possibly some of the the
benefits of religion it turns out that
seventh-day adventists live an average
of 10 years longer than the average
American life expectancy now some of the
places where people live the longest
includes Sardinia Italy Okinawa Japan
has a lot to do with diet over there but
also other things spirituality and other
lifestyle activities but let's look at
why the Adventists live longer they eat
a plant-based diet which I'm told that's
good for you this doesn't mean that they
don't eat meat they just don't eat a lot
of meat they also take the idea of the
Sabbath very seriously so they are
decompressing the stress about 84
percent of health care dollars are spent
because a bad food choice is inactivity
and unmanaged stress and they have
cultural ways of managing stress
managing stress through their Sabbath
and then their social network reinforces
the right behavior so this is
interesting because this is kind of the
the good part of religion that everybody
sort of tosses away and because there's
so much crazy extremism usually I think
that's warranted Cara I'm gonna let you
start
as the as the resident resident a the
resident atheist when you see something
like this can you acknowledge that there
are some benefits to completely I mean
this is not a new concept either in the
literature that religion kind of
improves health and religion improves
measures of psyche like psychiatry and
self-esteem and all of these things like
people seem to be happier healthier now
I don't think it has anything to do with
religion per se I think it has
everything to do with the social
structure that religion provides for
people
unfortunately atheists you know I think
fundamental to being an atheist is that
we're not organized and so what you
don't have are these support groups you
should start the atheist organization
there are people don't go every Sunday
and they don't know no answer but that's
there's so much sitting and standing and
everything that's like you know it's
like a good workout for your average
seventh-day adventists are an
interesting Bunch they're kind of people
call them the Old Testament Christians
so they're a bit like like Jewish
Christians in in some of their customs
and I think that a lot of those have to
do with really yeah so like Jews from
Connecticut yeah exactly like Jews from
Texas I'm so I grew up in Texas you know
yeah other southern girl I knew where
like you and I grew up Mormon yeah and
I'd be interested to see if Mormons have
similar life expectancy because in in
the same vein Mormons don't drink they
don't drink caffeine they are really
involved in the social kind of stuff and
they're they're just healthy
family-oriented people and of course
that's like the one thing I took away
from it when I grew up in a Mormon
household I also think there was
something to be said about like I've
thought a lot about you know when when
you believe that there's this God and
you know he or she or whatever is in
control of our life therefore you know
we don't have to ask the wise we don't
the ponder the questions we don't
distress about well what if I did this
is this gonna happen in my life in my
career in my this and
that and we are in constant we live in
anxiety and fear over all of these
questions but if you just kind of are in
a constant state of surrender the stress
doesn't exist like I was even holding my
newborn he was fighting taking a nap so
bad this thing that was so good for him
and I'm like why do you fight this thing
for fighting me all the time in a high
chair it's good for you to sit in a high
chair you know all these things they're
all good for you when you're fighting it
and I'm like we do the same as adults we
fight constantly the flow life is
happening and we're fighting against it
it's got to age us and caused so much
stress in our lives these people are not
fighting the flow yeah
they're just living their lives and this
very you know peaceful I don't really
have any you know concerns about life I
know I'm being taken care of so of
course that's gonna help you live longer
there I like that what so how do we take
that peace the three of us all agree is
a good piece how do we take that flow
piece that that peaceful peace and then
not necessarily directly connected to
religion but to connect it to just sort
of a lot of people do that mindfulness
like my meditation and and some of the
kind of concepts that they take out of
more Eastern philosophies not
necessarily religions but I do want to
point out that there are also high
levels of correlation between
intelligence and depression and so yes
there is something about constantly
questioning and being scientific and
thinking very hard that might cause some
psychiatric imbalances in people or vice
versa I mean there's it's not causal
here it's a high correlation
you're saying ignorance is bliss I'm
saying ignorance is bliss and I'd rather
not be ignorant I'd honestly rather know
ten years older that me I would I would
and so I think it's it's really about
what is the goal here I don't want to
live that long in in the dark it's just
not that interesting to me well you got
you got to my last question because
would you would you sacrifice a couple
years on your life to feel that your
life was more enlightened rather than
easy no III
think that there you had a good point I
think there's a way to find that
sanctity within your own skull rather
than having to like be a part of a
religious sect I think that you can and
that is the mindfulness practice and
being conscious and awakened and it's
just it's it's harder to do whenever I
guess at a certain level intelligence
when you're constantly questioning and
asking the questions that I'd rather ask
the questions I've been that way since I
was a child I'd rather just die ten
years earlier I'm sorry I'll son I'm
with you and actually yeah that's rough
for the kid but yeah besides that it's
fine
yeah I mean I'm with both of them on
this and that's why we're doing this
show because I want to show you that
there can be some level of intelligence
and also some level of fun and that not
everything is just this terrible awful
things yeah you can have both it's
possible to have both I mean just
because you're smart doesn't mean you're
gonna die yeah you take away from that I
was at your house a couple weeks ago you
were a hell of a time in the middle of
the day in the pool and you're a strong
person so you can't have fun I'm smart
that's your that same time all right
well moratoria forbes has come out with
a list of the highest paid actors and
actresses and there's some really really
interesting stuff here so let's take a
look at the five highest paid actors and
actresses okay so number one for the
women Sandra Bullock she pulled in 51
million dollars last year Jennifer
Lawrence 34 million Jennifer Aniston 31
million that one kind of surprised me
because she doesn't seem to be doing
that much
Gweneth Paltrow 19 Angelina Jolie 18 so
the top 10 females added up to 226
million dollars we're just showing you
the top five there and then for the men
Robert Downey jr. is 75 million dollars
Dwayne Johnson I mean I just saw a GI
Joe - really 52 million dollars Bradley
Cooper 46 million Leonardo DiCaprio 39
and Chris Hemsworth 37 million and the
top 10 men added up to four hundred and
nineteen million so I'm going to start
where you brought us Nikki before the
show started you brought up an
interesting point about
you want to bring it back first and then
we'll go from there I'd be interested to
know like what Sandra Bullock has
brought in in terms of box office
numbers versus Robert Downey jr. because
if they're both relatively the same and
that and Sandra's still getting like
half the amount of money that Robert
Downey jr. is getting then that's you
know that's really an imbalance but if
Robert Downey jr. is bringing in twice
as much to the box office in Sandra book
then I look at that and I go well if
he's bringing in a billion and she's
bringing in half then yeah you should
pay him more right so okay so we don't
know that specifically I think it's I
think it's a great yeah but so just
using the information we have there
still does seem to be an issue with yeah
if Robert Downey was pulling in twice
the box office I think the more
fundamental problem is that the movies
that are being written are being written
for leading men and so yes he's going to
be pulling in more box office if the
scripts that are out there and available
and the movies that are being funded are
all movies where men are the leads right
and this is a this is historic in
Hollywood you like I worked in the
sciences for a long time before I came
into production and I started working in
front and behind the camera and I would
people talk about sexism and stem all
the time right science technology
engineering math and how women don't
have the opportunities that men have and
how we're working really to push through
the glass ceiling and when I got to
production I thought it would be a
relief oh my [ __ ] god is it it's
almost worse it's almost worse than
Hollywood than it is in the sciences
women don't have as many opportunities
available to them so if they don't have
those opportunities they're not gonna be
able to get the box office which we and
graduate we're talking about people like
Sandra Bullock who still made like what
50 million dollars like Iran or give a
[ __ ] right but if we if we actually
translated that down to the camera
operator the two women who have a chance
I mean I work on a show where finally
this season we were able to get some
female directors on the show
we had besides the Creator herself we
had not had any in three seasons female
directors and it's like where are these
women they're out there but they're not
getting the same opportunities dps yeah
especially these camera grip yeah yeah
like you just don't know you really
don't so like that's where the big
struggle is I do think that how much
though is is that women don't
necessarily gravitate to those jobs I
mean are there are there a lot of women
that want to be yeah in kind of a work
yeah yeah yes they're actually I had a
female jib operator on the last show
like I did a daily live show on pivot
for almost a year and the jib which is
one of the hardest camera operate it's
really heavy
she was female she was amazing she
obviously wanted to be in camera off I
just don't think also I don't think the
society says like that's a job you
should have as a girl like as a girl you
should be in front of the camera or your
wardrobe or wardrobe makeup yeah makeup
I can tell you they're almost always
women yeah for the record our director
Amira is a girl and she's fantastic
I do want to say that I do think it is
changing in terms of women ly female
leads you know
Hunger Games is a good example Sandra
Bullock in gravity angelonia Angelina
Jolie and every action movie she's ever
done I think that it is changing it is
getting better so that's that's that's
something positive I also I don't I
would what I would like to know what the
International value of the those men are
as opposed to the women because that
also could have something to do with it
it's like an ideals
well no I mean in terms of like it does
a box office internationally like it you
know our people internationally more
likely to go see a Robert Downey jr.
film then they are a Sandra Bullock film
or a Jennifer Aniston film you know
dwayne johnson he's really big
internationally so why
but that I think is part of it that's a
lot of this isn't all equal information
because if Robert Downey jr. is an Iron
Man people love going to those math
versus gravity which I absolutely love
the whole let's look at all the action
heroes out there you have to put I mean
it's newsworthy when there's a female
action hero a comic hero and oh okay now
we're gonna make a movie about that but
like most of them are men I mean just
right now you look at every billboard
here in Los Angeles for Expendables 3
there's about 87 men I forget her name
she was actually they did a Wonder Woman
pilot and she would that fail they tank
but I think it's her that's in that but
there so I was looking at it's not a
huge building on Sunset Boulevard I was
like oh look at all this men and one
woman
that's hilarious because I seem to be
nuts what we're talking about I mean
I've seen that probably 50 times and
every time I'm looking is there a woman
is there a woman is it had it all so
kelsey grammer how did he become an
action star
well somehow he's in it so I don't know
how that happened on this just the
numbers you know we say these numbers I
have 50 million 75 million but like it's
nothing like these people are literally
making more than we all make ever in our
whole lives as an actress okay because
we make a lot we make those troubles I'm
very rich yeah we make those companies
very very wealthy and it is it's it's
and herbalist Sandra Bullock is selling
that movie people are going to see it
because she is in it yeah you know so
she should get paid a lot of money
because if you knew the kind of money
that they are making on the other end
you'd be like oh well then yeah she
should be making that amount of money
for carrying a movie and making it so
right but is there a point where is
there a point where they price
themselves out because
I went to see Planet of the Apes last
week and literally a popcorn and a soda
was more than the ticket you know to be
like is the rest of that where people
are eventually you're gonna be like you
know what I'm just not gonna go I mean
because I do think that we've got our
priorities a bit unbalanced in this
country and I do think that it's a bit
weird that Sandra Bullock makes fifty
million dollars in a year because but we
do that we make that decision it's the
same thing with professional athletes
like they make so much money
it's insane huh and then you've got you
know obviously here's a [ __ ] like PBS
you know like here comes the NPR like
socialist over here but like yeah
exactly first responders teachers you
know whatever visit like they don't they
don't make nearly the same kind of money
I think you're right Sandra Bullock
deserves that given the current
landscape I think the current landscape
is weird and I do think it's kind of
cool that we're starting to see that
change you're starting to see the rise
of the YouTube star you're starting to
see the rise of the individual self-made
oh it's shifting it really really really
is shifting where people can make a web
series and own their own content and
that is power now and they can usually
live off of it like it is not all over
LA we're seeing these like co-op kind of
places pop up where they're these
writing studios and these kind of
produce and where people own their own
business but they don't want to buy a
whole storefront and they don't want to
work in an apartment so they pay like
200 bucks to be a part of this group and
they can go have a desk and and the
reason that is happening is because so
many people are making it they're
actually making enough money to get by
on their own as an entity I guess I
guess from me I think you know I you
have to look at it in the context if
you're making a movie that's gonna gross
50 you know the five hundred million
dollars or whatever it is and you're the
face of that yes you should get a large
percentage of that but if you're making
an indie film and you have no idea what
its gonna make you know and you just
want to do it it's a great script you
want to do it you get scale and you show
up and you do your job or a hundred
dollars a day and then you say hey I'll
take two percentage points of the back
end if this thing ends up doing really
well because yeah I gave you my face I
did my time but you don't have to pay me
upfront I think that it it is in the
context what movie are you making what
what is gonna be the box-office and if
you keep bringing the money
you should get paid that's what being an
artist is all about right you do some
stuff for money and you do some stuff
really good I know I gotta I gotta keep
it short but like I was the other day I
was talking online about how I want to
get an electric car and I was asking for
advice and every response was get a
Tesla Model S and I was like I feel like
I shouldn't have to point this out and I
literally got responses from people like
you're on TV and you can't afford that
car yeah and I'm like I just think that
there's what ends up happening is that
Sandra Bullock makes fifty million
dollars and so people go
anybody who I've ever seen in front of
the screen is rich yeah and what they
don't understand is in a movie like that
to people get top billing they might
make five million each and then
everybody underneath it makes like eight
hundred a day and money goes away we get
paid ten thousand dollars and we get a
thousand dollars of it because we well
there's taxes okay and they took like
half which is like half because they
think that you make that year-round and
you don't you make it your pride one
reason yeah and they're like oh you make
that out here so we're gonna take half
of your money and then outside of that
you have to pay a lawyer and you have to
pay an agent and you have to have
manager then if you're on a show like me
you have to pay a publicist and then you
have to pay a stylist but your publicist
showed up yeah she's working so I'm just
saying like the amount of money that we
have to dish out to actually just do our
jobs
yeah is insane all that being said all
that being said I want 1500 that means
that we're still very lucky to be able
to have a creative job where we have a
creative I love a job we love where I
can at least make rent yes like to me
it's make rent and I'm about to pay $199
a month for a lease on a new electric
car and I'm very happy that I can afford
it again the Prius I'm getting I think a
Chevy spark and it's so cute as a spark
that's the new electric it's very cute
Oh John really drives one oh there you
go regular TYT view but a record I do
want to just say I actually am in the 1%
it's the other 1%
close I'm actually closer to that 1%
certainly than the other one but you
what you wear it well
alright I'm gonna let you guys pimp
yourselves out for the good people Cara
right over there all right Cara Santa
Maria comm that's where you can find all
my stuff I do a weekly podcast called
talk nerdy cool science podcast
downloaded every week on Mondays from
iTunes and stitcher you can also see the
work that I do locally in Southern
California on SoCal connected on KCET
and internationally now on TechKnow on
al jazeera america give us your best
actress sales no you could just follow
me on twitter at nikki gloutch and on
instagram at nick ni k DeLoach alright
there you go thank you guys for watching
comment like what else do they do I
don't subscribe subscribe you really do
clean up all my facts alright thank you
guys for watching and we'll do this
again next week